when you see the sun rise from the top
of the world
it was just the most beautiful thing you
could imagine
my first
tip would be to just start
the difference between most successful
people and
unsuccessful people is that the
successful people just gave it a shot
and they just took that first step
small steps make the biggest difference
there were so many moments
when i've been in the himalayas where i
felt like i couldn't take another step i
couldn't do anything more
and it's so easy to get paralyzed by the
enormity of the challenge and lose sight
that the step in front of you is all you
have to ever worry about
my next tip visualize
i'd make a playlist of music that will
transport me to the mountain as soon as
i put it on shut my eyes and i can
imagine myself climbing that peak
just taking the time to really visualize
what it would mean to achieve it i think
that most people give up because they
lose sight of their dream they forget
why they started
spend more time in nature
i always ran as a way to get fit and i
would go to the forest the things that
became really highly emotional and and
i'd get really upset about suddenly
weren't such a big deal
stop letting your ego get in the way
your ego can be the biggest wall that
you have to climb the most successful
people in life are the ones who are able
to be honest and vulnerable with others
the more you build up a wall around you
the more you have to pretend to be
someone that you're not
i don't think that just getting to the
top of a mountain makes you
a good person or a successful person
for me success comes down to can you get
to that point by being a compassionate
person to others by being in touch with
yourself being respectful of the
environment around you
i don't believe that you have to be
ruthless to get what you want in life
my final tip is
you have to trust
in something whether it's
yourself whether it's in god whether
it's in nature the universe
but just having that trust that it will
work out somehow and if it doesn't work
out in the way i want then maybe i'll
learn something from it when you have
been to the top of the world you
appreciate
such simple things you
you don't want to have
power or money or status or material
items you want to have great connections
with your family because when you do
think you're going to die they're all
you think about
you want to feel that feeling when
you've been on your feet for 24 hours
and you're still
climbing and you think
wow the human body is amazing those are
the moments i think that have made me
feel
most successful and ultimately those are
in some ways some of the hardest moments
in life to find
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video